hello everybody markiplier here we're
back with umm let's play minecraft I'm
here with some Bob and Wade hey I uh hi
everybody
um we got a new world yeah don't know
what we're gonna do today um thinking I
hope we should that we let's uh I think
you'll be fun if we did like it kind of
just a simple like it build a nice
little house and and ya know we could we
could like start a mine maybe yeah that
no I like that idea I know means we do
we do a lot of complex builds and it'd
be nice just kind of relax yeah yeah
Wade you okay whisk yeah can we get like
a little tiny farm or something yeah oh
yeah yeah I usually do the farm um um it
uh maybe one of you guys could um you
guys could do the farm I'll uh I'll take
that I'll get off on I'm gonna get some
would be a little yeah minister you
start getting some wood I'm gonna dig
and try to start a mind on please do um
yeah get legal elite all definitely at
least get coal cuz huh we're gonna
definitely need a lot of coal yeah yeah
you know you guys know how minecraft is
yeah I know it's crazy sometimes and
yeah anyway I'm not I'm having honest
not enough yeah I know it's just now I'm
having a few sips of um Dr Pepper here
I've had a couple drops of a Yingling
I've got a big uh my favorite cup
it's the Irish coven Twilight Capo I
just it's a big glass of ice water but
it it's a really big cup ah okay ah I
wish I had a big cup I don't I I used
too bad didn't me too it's really it's
nice
oh I found a seat I found seeds yeah
okay so good good axle
I'm very happy to hear that you do you
want to go for any um any more advance
farm stuff do you want to try for like
carrots are no but let's not get too
complicated here just dumb I see we
disconnected again yeah you know but I
can't I can't believe you have a fixed
day yeah ah I know I'm gonna go buy now
but you know it is what it is yeah I
don't mean you get used to like
makes me laugh every time he does it's
where uh where do we want to set up um
set up camp um well I I I'm gonna build
a crafting table
Oh a bottle should I buy sure top of
that down and overlooking this little
like middle cliff area there's actually
a ravine over there well there is ah mmm
see it a kinda you know I see some coal
second out of there Bob what if what if
we built a nice little two-story house
like right here so we overlooked this
little water in the ravine yeah let me
I'll make it on this little bowl that
I'm on here so I'll level level this off
and just get that started so we can have
something set up you careful hold shift
while you're on the edge so you don't
fall off yeah okay I've got 12 spruce
wood I'm gonna make them into planks
I've got 60 Spurs wood planks are d2 if
you want to start I'm a foundation I'm a
I'm a I'm a crafting table it'll
probably I've got one oh we have an
extra one okay that's fine that's fine
it'll help us get started you know we
can yeah I can put it out by the farm -
I like to have one out there that's
that's true yeah it really helps when
it's right out there where you need it
mm-hmm it's a little little trick that
that a lot of a lot of first-timers
don't - yeah remember I remember running
back and forth all the time back when I
first started playing yeah yeah
cuz I left my one crafting table set up
and I didn't we we used to be noobs I
mean way back in the day yeah I think
just just for my own sanity I'm gonna
make this whole floor wood here so this
will be the level that the house is on
and I'm going to smooth it out one and
put well down so down one blow from what
we are yeah so that we've got all wood
flooring in oh well then we're gonna
need more wood let's throw this chest at
somebody you guys can use it to help us
store items I don't need it down there
I've guys didn't know chests I think we
store items here yeah and I'm sorry you
guys hit there's eight or nine cobble so
we can get a furnace built um you got
that was just I've got I've got I've got
a buncha cobble Gary I did not get
enough cobble I've got 16 so er
her can Iona we're going on a couple
furnaces for I'm gonna ask for some
torches but you guys should probably use
a polite no I'm here no I've got to yeah
I've got I've got a um eight yeah I've
got at sixteen now we have swords and a
leather armor so we should be good if
you know zombies come banging down our
door you know like walking like to do
that don't they yeah okay I like that I
like that the program yeah then Walking
Dead yeah there's a good one that's one
of my favorites was if you guys have
never seen or heard of The Walking Dead
it's a great show it is oh man it's
great definitely yeah worth worth a
little pirating err or Netflix or
whatever I did on it we would all work
liked it oh I believe it is oh dear I
broke my shovel oh oh was it just one
yeah well okay you did get cobble
remember you can make a I I uh yeah I
guess I'll put the crafting table up oh
wow it's a bat look well yeah
those are those are so pretty new kicked
again I've almost got it
I've almost got the bat in the Sun hang
on I'm gonna get this gonna get this
shot yeah look and zombie moans just
flying across the sky ah these are these
are helpful admin that helps us out on a
server he's you know yeah the surfers
Vox Populi by the way it's great sir
it's really generous guy
oh look good look at the little bit look
at it I'm just gonna chase him around
for a little bit huh I thought you were
calling a zombie about 400 quid on I
wouldn't do that
what what is it was haha what does that
even mean I don't know that's not it's a
very friendly way that's what I saw
myself having a nice hearty chuckle mmm
is this your mind Wade yep oh I like the
entrance it's very cool I just want to
mark it off to make sure that we didn't
you know got its ornate in a way I'm uh
oh did you guys know um if you burn wood
you get this thing called charcoal and
it's exactly the same as cold so yeah
that's a really good it's a really good
substitute for coal of here having
trouble starting out yeah it's really
good I mean it's helpful it's more of an
it
ants minecraft technique but you know I
don't know what it means that I've dug
down this far and I just hits and I'm
assuming there might be water I'm gonna
proceed cautiously from this point
sounds reasonable don't want you to you
know die or anything yeah whoa hey whoa
something happened here something
interesting there's like plants of
either carrots or potatoes I'm not sure
can you harvest them is that I play or
not it's fully ground I mean if we're
trying to demonstrate the basics of
Minecraft going with other crops might
be a little bit too far huh yeah oh yeah
that's true yeah should just start with
just wheat I'm all the way back up I
broke my wooden pickaxe I think it's
time to upgrade
I can I can get you a cobble one set up
okay oh yeah I don't know what you're
making this house out of but I can
supply with some more cobble wood it's a
source would yeah spruce wood hand
here's mom I thought yours some more
planks and here's some even more planks
haha I got it what if I went with spruce
wood with a cobble roof Oh with cobble
stairs yeah yeah yeah yeah okay
ooh I found more crops just it's a good
ticket combo here wait I'll get you two
I don't know I don't know hey that's a
little lace I just replenished your I
probably need them uh-huh where are you
wait mind you I just gave you all my
cobble you said like 37 blocks they're
awesome yeah I'll keep thank you thank
you to get him I got a cool cool cool
yes thanks mark yeah I know you need
them I was I was just about to walk back
out there I appreciate I got I'm doing
me I'm getting even more you know not
now some YouTube channels I've seen
there's a lot of conflict whenever they
have multiple players it's nice to see
us all getting along what so it's really
it's really it's about the Minecraft you
know it's not really us no one wants to
come here and watch watch a couple of
idiots yell at each other or I know I
mean you would never get anything done
what's what's the point exactly
what why would you watch a TV show or
nothing happened it's like they'd spend
three episodes building something then
blow it all up and like yeah their
viewers are like I really wanted to see
how to do that and I didn't want to see
all this stupid just random X
loschen you know fifth-grade humor yeah
um Bob could I have some of that
cobblestone yeah if you're not you have
much all of it yeah I only need five
pieces exactly follow okay yeah what do
you need it for my I'm gonna make a
furnace oh okay yeah it's a good idea I
got it yeah oh thank you look at this
guy's everybody look at this boom
furnace butt out good go on place place
oh yeah yeah I know how furnaces are
used for cooking or so if you get like
an iron or you can cook it down to an
iron ingot yeah and I'm gonna use it
right now to make some charcoal so that
way we can Nestle it at us that's yeah
cuz night is coming guys and you have to
get anything happen but don't forget you
can burn wood planks and use actual wood
blocks to make the coal but you don't
have to burn wood blocks and so that way
you guys can save item I'm Bernie that's
what it blocks with wood planks and it's
very efficient I found some tail economy
right there I got some food for uh are
you just gonna kill him yeah I mean we
don't have a farm set up so yeah I don't
have any way to make fence or anything
right now so alright well the house is
just about done
do you have any more planks mark um I
can get more really quickly before the
Sun goes I don't want to be caught out
here when it's dark I'm gonna try and
get this set up
oh I'm finding myself on the outside
looking in again cliff oh that's good
does yeah that's good
I like the little phraseology there yeah
thank you thank you
oh you cracked me up with oh man we are
a clever lot mmm okay we'll finish off
this last tree I'm gonna get the hell
out of the darkness I have found one
coal block this entire - sorry for
saying hell guys I'm sorry
oh it's okay laughs I think I'm gonna
get the heck out of here
okay I have more wood planks here you go
24 that's the best I could do at work um
uh I'm gonna yeah I'm gonna go ahead and
make some torches yeah I mean we you can
never have too many I'm gonna work brave
the perimeter and just you know um guys
everyone watching out there if you
didn't know if you put torches around
your house and light it up during the
night monsters don't spawn oh gosh
there's a zombie here Oh God
jeez oh you gonna be
he's just creepy gotta be okay with that
gonna see just he's really creepy I
don't know oh it's it looks like I did
it is a good luck and found some iron oh
all right really
this is sheep out here too there's a
couple sheep actually we can em sheep
give wool guys sheep give wool it's good
that's it's I mean you pretty much only
use it for beds really unless you're
doing you know some of the more
pointless yeah extra stuff I think I uh
zom what whoa hello oh there's there's a
witch real oh man so I've actually done
encountered one this is oh this is great
opportunity guys everyone watching out
there this is a new mob that was added
when was it added one point for update
any point for ya and dumb yeah it's a
witch look Wow crazy it's excited they
throw bottles and I think it's like
poison don't see it right near that are
like potions and stuff yeah it's right
over there seem to be hurting me I must
have residual godmode from when we were
doing a little creative stuff before
sorry I didn't mean to have that left
over uh okay no here we go God my table
Thank You Tommy thank you so much Oh
know how it hurt I do believe I
encountered a zombie my travels uh Wade
get out here you need to get back to the
house you'll you're in danger out there
I'm on
we don't want to lose especially that
iron that you got yes that's some good
stuff that I'm gonna need to make an
iron pickaxe because I found some
redstone apparently a stone pickaxe is
not efficient for getting redstone Oh oh
hey there you are good be careful the
witch out there
where is he god I've always want to see
it we're on the UH one must be gone away
huh oh no it's on this side of the UM
it's on this side of the house look at
it okay okay hey ah oh no miles of some
poison oh no she made it inside Oh No oh
alright
okay that was efficient good good use of
teamwork yeah alright oh man do we have
a chest bill I know I have chest right
here let me put them down like BAM done
I'm putting a couple steaks into the
furnace here I'll put some pork chops
once you're done okay I think do steaks
give the same as pork chops in terms of
health um you know I don't remember or
food food rather they don't give health
directly well yeah yeah yeah didn't mean
to make myself look like an idiot
haha that's alright we all make mistakes
right happens to everyone
alright puts my spare items in this
chest if you guys need any of those feel
free I'm here take these torches before
you go if you're going down back in your
mom okay oh I wasn't really gonna go
anywhere I was just uh oh that's you Bob
so I missed ya
the leather armor it's threw me out a
second there huh uh never bud
easy mistake okay so alright I've got
some more steaks out here Wow
you know we're doing pretty good I mean
we're only 15 minutes in we got a house
almost all built yeah I put a lot more
cobblestone in this chest whenever
daylight comes we can now get this roof
finished yeah you know what I'm gonna do
it I'm gonna most wanna and III but I
was gonna leave it half open cuz I know
we wanted to make make it multi floor ah
do you happen to have a stick on you Bob
yeah how many do you need just one okay
sure I'm adding I'm doing some crazy
guys I'm making a
farm without water ha ha ha that's it
seems kind of ironic it's actually
possible this is a really advanced
minecraft technique but um if you plant
the seeds before you know you know how
most farms you need water and then the
soil turns darker color which means
right charter if you actually put the
seeds down before the dirt goes back to
regular dirt the seeds will grow huh
yeah I've got on one wall does anybody
have a wall so we can start making a bet
there are more sheeps over there if you
use your iron for shears you could get
more sheep out there you know there's
like um well I'm
once again longing to return it gets
funnier every time you get cake it is
pretty comical yeah it's a very comical
occurrence it doesn't ever get
frustrating oh come on EU would imagine
that it would but I know you think so I
mean doesn't it make you just a little
bit angry little ah I feel like the
communica a spec that adds kind of
flavours it up enough to override any
feelings I may be harboring yeah huh
Skelton just hit me in the head with an
arrow you think that would hurt more
than it did to what where are you I
don't oh you're getting the Sheep oh I
it's the arrow is sticking out of your
head ha ha funny it's funny all that
that may not work just another cool
thing about Minecraft yeah yeah do you
have enough haters on you oh no I do not
okay okay okay I've got two wool can you
guys see me there's enough pay guys near
the Harrow up huh
what I can sum on I'm on top of the
world
oh I see you you know what would be so
cool Bob you know would be soaked what's
that if you bridge like the top of our
house all the way to that little alcove
or that you know with a little little
outcrop over there I you know we could
do we could build a lighthouse on there
oh-ho how do we do that that would be
neat
it's a complex ordeal um I guess I look
nice hello stone maybe yeah we'd have to
get a lot of a lot of glowstone together
I thank you that was like there's a
naturally occurring mine right here that
might have had some coal Oh oh yeah
that's lucky well um let's um I'm gonna
go in okay I don't have it could one of
you I don't have torches or a stone
pickaxe so I'm I've only got three
torches I do have a picnic oh wait yeah
wait should have an extra stone I'm not
going down there I've got a bunch of
torches I got a bunch of torture it's
too scary down there I'm not going down
there no no way
okay yeah okay um there's some progress
made on this form if you guys look
see these three mighty see that and yes
you're growing yeah see I don't know if
it's as fast but you know come on how I
woulda met I would imagine it's probably
not as fast that might be true you know
it might need water to grow at maximum
speed
yeah I'll be thinking investing a stone
sword would be a good idea at this point
a possibly why you got some resistance
down there there's about three or four
spiders all lined up ready to uh you
know take me down okay all right um I
prefer not to indulge them on their
awareness yeah yeah you could become one
of them Wade what is that you could
become a zombie I have a one cobblestone
block there Bob uh yeah thank you
oh you're both on the roof I didn't they
can get up in inside I made the stairs
already sauce that's nice I use actually
if you look at the stairs - it's pretty
cool it looks like I place one of them
that's just like hovering in the air I
could realize one more stick leave you
is you took a block like that and that's
oh I placed it on top of that and then
the way it works in Minecraft if you cut
it away it just stays Wow pretty cool
yeah yeah that works with on sec go
ahead the beep it's a neat McCain lot
it's a good it's a good tip to have nice
sure like that it makes it mmm you know
you keep it
I put there's a stick over behind you
wait over there I through oh thank you
didn't see him if when I threw it that's
okay I appreciate now that it's day um
could one of you get me a stone axe I'm
gonna go do some serious lumberjacking I
don't have uh yes cereals for one or
else I would I have the materials for
that kami one sec here
anybody have some extra torches um uh
yeah yeah Bob's got you covered
Bob got you covered yeah Bob you're just
full of stuff aren't you you want a
stone axe was that mark yes that's mark
please please there you go thank you
nasty some torches lighting gorches
ooh one too many
oh whatever hits oh I picked them all up
hey guy I got your earth at Nam Thank
You yo up the Monty Python sketch adios
and the Monty Python sketch I'm a
lumberjack and I'm okay
oh yeah I love that one I should yeah
asbestos circle I've probably got to
watch it again after we're done here
right yes Lee oh wow this stone axe is
so much better here welcome sir
thank you thank you thank you okay I
feel like I feel like we've got a lot
accomplished so far yeah and I in record
time we're only 21 minutes in and no we
guy I'm pretty pleased with our progress
I'm not going to lie here I'm uh
my lover jacket okay is that is that
stuck in your head town yeah if Billy's
I hate it I hate theater huh um I could
perhaps use some help clearing this out
there's all of a sudden three or four
skeleton archers perhaps I should just
uh quit on this endeavor uh yeah that it
doesn't seem worth it I mean we don't
want you dying yeah I did see some coal
but I guess I can try to find it my mind
yeah just use yours bit more controlled
it's unfortunate whatever well when we
when we get some better armor and stuff
we can you know chemi to difficult to
clear that out to have a more
cobblestone Wayne are you guys okay
moment but I will go dig some right now
try to finish off the roof up here now
right underneath you there is that pit
that I was trying to avoid but the very
top layer is really just cobble and you
can dig out there safely just don't
venture too far down mmm
I might go for that okay yeah you don't
be really a bad or be a you know for us
to do if we all were like decked out in
an iron armor and we just all walk down
in a line and clear out the monsters in
the mine there that would yeah that
better be okay wonderful actually that'd
be fun oh wow holy oh oh yeah I hit
bedrock
oh I bedrock already Wow you're way way
down there yeah in case um anyone
watching bedrock is on the bottom layer
of the Minecraft world below it is the
nether actually which I believe like
four layers up is where you want to be
for diamonds ideally um it's been 12
somewhere not yeah somewhere in there I
believe I mean I don't think anyone's
got the exact number down it's kind of
you know it's complicated with the way
it is but you know close around there
somewhere there hey thanks for the iron
by the way whoever stuck the iron in
there oh we had two pieces in there I
made an iron pick so I can get this
redstone okay no problem
no I'm cooking this last piece and then
I'm gonna make some more charcoal oh
dear
what I'm finding coal them rogue P
throat my pickaxe oh don't do that it
was an accident art out I wasn't I
wasn't blaming you I wasn't leaving you
I was just I was fooling around okay
these um these carrots and potatoes are
done I'm actually going to harvest them
because I think our audience is a bit
smarter you know then the average
minecraft special smarter than the
average bear hahaha
still that's fine
okay yeah carrots and potatoes were
added in 1.4 as well I'm with the way
and bats actually - bats - were in
1.4 I didn't think that was with the
other ones yes I did blow sir
I uh if I remember I thought those were
for point or 1.4.2 it might be you know
thinking back I I don't know I didn't
you know I always go over release notes
and everything but I didn't that all a
life student would be those or more
there's one released and I remember bats
for the thing bats carrots and potatoes
mm-hmm I'm planting carrots and plant
carrots you know they work just like
wheat you don't need water you can put
them right down and yeah they grow they
grow just about the same as wheat you
know little progress over time and
mm-hmm how's the UH how's the wheat
looking uh it's slow going I think I
might actually if we could get like
enough iron I know it's probably gonna
be a while but if we can get enough iron
to make a bucket a minute I do have two
more iron ore block ooh um mmm yeah I
have to uh come back yeah I have the two
that you cooked and if we cook just one
more we'll be good yeah sure I can come
back with I thanks wait I've also got
almost a full stack of cobblestone for
you Bob I actually have a stack right
now I'm about to finish up with buy I uh
I appreciate you getting that anyway
sure do I need it for the bridge of the
lighthouse or something I'm not sure
that that would be cool I think that'd
be interesting I'm just trying to finish
off the top level right now so we can
kind of oh yeah get get settled in and
everything will be taken care of you
know we can find out a lot of coal maybe
we could do stone brick I've got um I've
got charcoal cooking holy help fourteen
pieces oh sorry I said hello Wow Wow
I keep saying how mark I keep saying bad
words but yeah this is surprising you
know we got so much car charcoal here
now oh is that is I've got not a massive
shark regular coal that's all I've
managed to find so I've got you beat
Wade all right so you're gonna put the
items in this chest here that one okay
the large one are the the single one the
large one I'm going to go
head and cook the iron alrighty
our house is all taken care of there
gentlemen looking good actually
EDG have you seen the upstairs wait I'll
show everyone had not show everyone
who's watching yes go ahead mark after
you it's like oh you know upstairs room
going on here and yeah eventually like a
to put the beds the beds up here or it's
like I'm going to bed early
hahaha they're in a new bed oh I see
pika oh okay alright let's get serious
here let's get serious and if you if you
whenever you go outside mark if you take
a look but I get it yeah the I used an
inset at rooftop er which if you look at
you'll see there's like a stone missing
on the corner there well I see you now
that's that's a lot like the stair
mechanic that I demoed earlier yeah yeah
yeah it's it's I got you yeah oh well
that was that I think that makes it look
you know a little more a little nicer
here oh yeah that is nice and then
eventually we could um take out a wall
and connect even but that's we're way
later all that ice thing about this
though you can just break anything out
or or whatever you some extra iron
happens to have randomly appeared in
this little mini mine here
what hunted this entire night there's
iron over here that wasn't here before
haha that's lucky I guess I know you
know minecraft decided to be nice ah
that happens folks all right I got
enough for a bucket I'm gonna get some
water
and one of our wheat has grown up it's
all grown I'm gonna build a over here
here I'll mark it with a torch - yeah on
this on this corner of the house that
has a torch I'm gonna put a ladder up to
the roof just just you know for like
roof maintenance or anything like that
yeah you guys aren't gonna believe this
there's also random glowstone down here
now no way oh yeah that must be like
that's the exactly we were looking for
that's that's totally not our crazy
server admin I wouldn't think so
haha oh ouch how are you okay Ella fell
off the roof there okay yeah I've got a
couple apples I just take it I haven't
got the food production up and running
dad at how we'll survive we'll get there
we'll get there I'm going to attempt to
uh get this glowstone for us alright you
know is there hot you could only get
that from the nether but normally that's
true all right I have given us water on
our farm work
thank you and I'm going to oh dear I
just tried to jump off a cliff oh I
don't do take care don't do that don't
do that don't do that that's uh that's
bad news bears ha ha ha ha ha ha I
happen to see what you attempt to do
there and you succeeded I would say yeah
ok
ah hey we're in more pieces of coal I
thought ha ha ha we actually got 30
seconds the whole damn time you
Danny wait my god I can't put it
is I better see what you trying to
do that asteroid this is not a Buddhist
thing the whole time you've been stupid
like that this great great character the
entire very subtle ha ha ha
oh my god all right we're out of time to
work we're on time damn it Wade yeah
yeah we almost say the whole episode I
would have been on like three minutes
Oh God it was just like Wade the whole
time like oh I see what you did do there
ha ha are so funny just like we're
Bob and I were actually trying
oh wait everything up so yeah
sorry everybody all right sir we unarmed
now I'm really attached to this idea
that I'm working on so give me like two
seconds well you were already a minute
over so we're closing up shop
no no expended progress all up are we
gonna blow this house up or what no no
no we're not gonna blow this house ami
no no don't do it Tommy dynamite
everywhere there is not please don't
dump me no all right that was what I was
doing so that the letter was safe oh I
was so excited about this idea I was
gonna demo edge safety huh all right so
thanks really
okay oh my god thank you everybody
so much for watching if anyone made it
to the end of the episode and as always
someone did we will see you in the next
video bye bye everybody
hi